our car Chester II Manuel Schafer says
BMW launched the 4 Series in 2013 as a
step up from its 3 Series that's a
little more exclusive and sporty it's
worked out BMW has sold more than
400,000 units since launching the 4
Series so no wonder it's only made minor
tweaks to the new 4 series range BMWs
heated the truism that if it ain't broke
don't fix it and so the car makers
barely modified its new 4 Series range
only BMW enthusiasts will spot
differences like the new standard buy
LED headlights or the slightly
redesigned front apron even though the
BMW 440 i.m sports coupe a that we
tested comes with an entirely different
front apron than the regular 4 Series
[Music]
BMV Manawa says they've stiffened the
suspension which you can really sense
the BMW 440 iku pay now really hugs the
road especially on corners Amano L also
loves the cars powerful output of 240
kilowatts or 326 horsepower
Loida the range has been given adaptive
dampers and more responsive steering
which still makes for a very comfortable
ride however these changes to the
suspension system don't apply to the
Cabrillo here BMW was happy with a
status quo
the 440 IQ pay we tested comes in BMWs
all-new snapper rocks blue paint finish
which is only available for the four
series
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the new 4 series range boasts novel LED
taillights and the headlights now
resemble those of the latest three and
five series the car maker claims the 440
i coupe a uses 7.7 liters per 100
kilometers though consumption will
certainly be higher when racing along at
a top speed of 250 kilometers this new
coupe a comes with a few more features
and lets you combine optional extras
more freely but it also costs 2,000
euros more than its predecessor
[Applause]
only small changes were made to the
copays interior they're intended to
lended a more refined feel an optional
8-speed steptronic automatic
transmission constant extra 2150 euros
and a sat-nav will add at least 2,000
euros to the price tag electronically
adjustable and heated seats are also
available in many four series trim lines
in Germany an entry level 4 series model
can be had for just over 40,000 euros
and all engines can be combined with
all-wheel X Drive if desired the large
435 D diesel is the only model available
exclusively with all-wheel-drive it'll
set you back at least 60,000 euros
emanuelle says the changes that have
been made are subtle yes superb he
thinks the 440 eye is a force to be
reckoned with though he's a little
disappointed the four series LED
headlights that look like those of the
3-series LED graphic does finish
ambition Shara
maybe it's BMWs way of harmonizing its
product range all for one and one for
all
you